Je pense qu'évidemment il y a beaucoup de
trucs visuels dans Monty piton et il y
a beaucoup de trucs cérébraux mais je veux dire que
c'était John C, vous savez qu'il était
intelligent tout le temps, vous connaissez Mike et moi,
nous voulons juste être drôles,
nous voyons Terry Jones  seulement étranger
étranger
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ne pensez-vous pas que le succès de
Monty Python vient de ce qu'est le
Vietnam et de ce qui est cérébral dans A Fish
Called Wanda
oh je suis désolé je suis désolé je suis  désolé je viens de
dériver là-bas pendant quelques instants euh
eh bien ouais je pense qu'il y a un peu de ça
dedans euh je pense euh évidemment il y a
beaucoup de trucs visuels euh
et euh il y a beaucoup de trucs cérébraux
mais je veux dire pas John te dit  sais qu'il
était intelligent tout le temps tu sais Mike
et moi nous voulons juste être drôles et hé
que pensez-vous du travail des
Beatles après leur séparation John Lennon a
écrit certaines des meilleures chansons de tous les temps après
leur séparation je veux dire je  pense imagine que
c'est euh mon préféré de tous les temps je pense à
toutes ces chansons contrairement à pe  services personnels
euh Eric le Viking est en fait venu d'un
livre que vous avez lu à l'origine pour votre
fils n'est-ce pas vrai oui j'ai initialement
écrit cette série de magasins appelée
la chanson The Very Viking pour mon fils bill
euh mais c'était euh vers 1983 et  J'ai
pensé que ça pourrait faire un très bon
film parce qu'il y a de bonnes images
dedans mais après un moment je me suis un peu ennuyé
avec ça j'ai pensé bien tu sais que tu l'as
écrit comme une histoire et c'est
publié comme un livre je veux dire je  Je ne veux
pas passer deux ans de ma
vie à en faire un film alors j'ai en quelque
sorte abandonné l'idée après en avoir essayé
quelques scripts et tout à coup j'ai
trouvé cette scène de viol qui est maintenant la
première scène de  le film et moi je l'avais
écrit pour autre chose et euh en
fait je l'ai trouvé dans un tirage au sort et j'ai
pensé que c'était une scène assez drôle
peut-être qu'il y avait une histoire là-bas alors
quand j'ai soudainement écrit quelque chose qui est
totalement différent donc même si ça
s'appelle Eric  le Viking
euh ce n'est pas le s
Je suis le livre pour enfants du tout, je veux dire qu'il n'y a pas de
scène Vape dans le livre de Jordan et euh je
viens d'utiliser quelques exemples du
dragon de la mer du Nord et de
traverser le monde
bien sûr, je n'ai pas écrit  pour
Bill
euh, c'est basé sur une histoire vraie basée sur l'
histoire de euh Cynthia Payne qui est une
vraie femme à Londres qui dirigeait ce
bordel dans une banlieue très respectable du sud de
Londres, personne ne le savait jusqu'à ce que
la police l'ait perquisitionné un jour
alors Eric les Vikings  genre de euh vraiment je
me remets plus sur la bonne
voie maintenant Terry imagine que je suis un riche
producteur célèbre d'Hollywood comment pourrais-tu
obtenir 12 millions de dollars de moi hmm
oh j'essaierais et essaierais de t'avoir
dans le lit, vous savez et voyez, mais cela
ne fonctionne généralement pas avec la plupart d'entre eux,
euh, alors la prochaine chose que je viens
vous voir avec cette merveilleuse idée
d'Eric le Viking et j'ai Alan
Lee pour dessiner toutes ces images  ces
belles photos parce qu'être un Hollywood
producteur je sais que tu ne sais pas lire donc je
te montre ces photos et je te raconte cette
histoire et euh et puis je te demande si tu vas au
lit avec moi mais
Charles je suppose et si j'étais un
déménageur très paresseux monter comment tu vendrais  ce
film à moi
eh bien si tu étais vraiment en retard
euh j'essaierais de te vendre pour trois
livres je pense que non Terry est-il vrai que
tu as donné un rôle à John Cleese afin
d'obtenir de l'argent de la Scandinavie euh
en fait je ne l'ai pas fait  Je ne veux pas du tout donner aux accros de Box,
euh ce qui s'est passé, c'est que John a proposé d'être
dans le film si nous étions vraiment sûrs de
ne pas pouvoir collecter de l'argent et j'ai dit non
non, je ne veux aucune référence à Monty Python
et  puis environ un mois plus tard, j'ai lu dans l'
un de nos affreux journaux anglais,
euh, une interview de John Cleese dans
laquelle il a dit qu'il allait
jouer un rôle dans mon film, donc j'ai dû le
lui proposer après, ce n'est plus  l'ensemble de
l'épisode du Haut Brésil une allégorie du
peuple anglais allemand et néerlandais dans les
îles Baléares et pendant t  il était
bien sûr que c'était avant tout dans mon
esprit quand je l'écrivais mais je pense que
maintenant j'ai tendance à penser que c'est plus une
allégorie générale à propos de euh
euh le genre de politiciens
qui disaient que
tout allait parfaitement bien vous
savez  Je veux dire euh en Angleterre, par exemple,
notre lait est tout radioactif de nos jours,
nous avons une sorte de fermes de moutons en
France dans les fermes de moutons en Ecosse
et au Pays de Galles, vous ne pouvez pas manger la viande à cause
de la radioactivité, il y a une sorte de euh 20
miles de cambian  Le littoral qui est
radioactif et Mme Thatcher
dit que la radioactivité est l'énergie la plus
respectueuse de l'environnement et la plus informative
qu'il y ait Terry pourquoi préférez-vous
Keaton WC Fields et Tatty à Charlie
Chaplin Champion était vraiment drôle mais il
voulait tout ce qu'il voulait que vous vous moquiez
de lui il  voulait que vous l'admiriez, il
voulait que vous vous sentiez désolé pour lui et je
veux dire quand vous regardez des films japonais, il
fait très rarement rire quelqu'un d'
autre alors que Keaton pourrait  en quelque sorte, euh,
il n'exigeait pas tout pour son propre
écran Persona à WC Fields serait en quelque
sorte euh, vous savez, se rendait vraiment
désagréable, surtout quand il avait
affaire à des enfants,
euh, je suppose que c'est juste parce
que j'aime Keaton en tant qu'homme, je pense  Je le
réfère à Chapman maintenant dans quel groupe de rock and
roll fait ce gars Chaucer dont vous avez
écrit un livre sur le jeu, il est mort il y a environ
600 ans
euh c'était un grand poète britannique pourrait dire que
vous connaissez Chaucer Jeffrey Chaucer il a
écrit le premier  les poèmes en
anglais ne peuvent pas être des contes tout ce genre de
choses et il a vécu en Angleterre au
14ème siècle
non
enfin Terry
es-tu content de me voir dans le miroir
tous les matins quand tu te réveilles
bien je ne sais pas comment faire  Je ne sais pas
comment dire ça en fait Terry euh
tu sais que je voulais prendre pendant
un bon moment mais je pense que tu
deviens pas si jolie un peu un
peu gros là et tu sais des
sacs  sous les yeux et j'ai
peur que ça tourne plutôt  moi je veux dire je
sais je sais tu sais que je t'aimais
beaucoup mais j'ai peur que ce soit un
peu éteint de nos jours
euh c'est un bon nouveau Mac Club
[Musique]